[Musik]
Francisco Garcia avilles ist einer der
Gründe das Spanien vorzeitig wählt denn
aviles ist denn fuente de grenadre
beliebt und seit einigen Wochen
Bürgermeister hier
alles in Ordnung möchtest du einen
Schluck wenn du mir einen gibst
und gibst du mir zwei Küsse na klar
setzte sich gegen den sozialistischen
Amtsinhaber durch nachdem er in die
rechtsaußenpartei VOX eingetreten war
zuallererst wegen der illegalen
Einwanderung
illegale Einwanderung ist etwas das in
diesem Land außer Kontrolle gerät sowie
derzeit in Frankreich
[Musik]
nationalismus
ist eine von vielen Orten in denen VOX
Stimmen gewann das Dorf lebt von der
Landwirtschaft Olivenbäume so weit das
Auge reicht und in den Hügeln offenbart
sich ein Widerspruch
besonders während der olivensaison die
von November bis März dauert kommt in
der Region viel Einwanderung hinzu
hauptsächlich Marokkaner aber im Moment
haben wir sehr viel Kontrolle über die
marokkanische Bevölkerung die Wahrheit
ist dass Sie bei uns bisher keinerlei
Probleme bereitet hat
Landwirtschaft traditionelle Werte des
findet sich in Andalusien bis zu den
Spielplätzen wie im Nachbarort erstes
sigura und bis in das Amtszimmer von
Bürgermeister Rossi Alberto Rodriguez
der Sozialist wurde bei der Kommunalwahl
wieder gewählt mit klassischen
sozialistischen Themen
wir tun alles um Arbeitsplätze und
Wohnungen zu schaffen der Stadtrat hat
mehrere Programme zum Thema
Beschäftigung durchgeführt und eine
Börse mit Beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten
eingerichtet
Leo Spanien gehe es wirtschaftlich gut
die Inflation sehr niedrig sagen die
Sozialisten die sich in der
traditionellen Rolle des kümmerers sehen
na wie geht es deiner Frau meine Frau
wollte heute nicht kommen um die anderen
zu begrüßen außerdem braucht sie ihre
Spritze na sowas aber auch
die Plakate sind die gleichen wie im
Nachbarort und doch scheinen die
beherrschenden Themen hier andere zu
sein
[Musik]
das größte Problem ist die Entvölkerung
der Mangel an jungen Menschen und die
Idee Industrialisierung die
Einwohnerzahl in der Stadt sinkt weil es
für die junge Bevölkerung die wir haben
schwierig ist außerhalb der
Landwirtschaft eine andere Art von
Arbeit zu finden und dann gehen sie
daneben hat der Bürgermeister auch hier
die Themen vorangebracht die den
Sozialisten in Spanien wichtig sind wir
haben eine Abteilung für die
Gleichstellung und Frauen gegründet mit
der wir in der Gemeinde Pionierarbeit
geleistet haben vor vier Jahren haben
wir diese Abteilung gegründet die in der
Stadt erhebliche Fortschritte erzielt
hat es ist ihr gelungen eine Kommission
gegen geschlechtsspezifische Gewalt
einzurichten
genau gegen solche Politik haben die
Rechtsaußen bei den Regionalwahlen
Stimmung gemacht voxtritt für die
traditionelle Familie auf
antifeministisch und gegen rechte
sexueller Minderheiten
am 28 Mai entschied sich das spanische
Volk eindeutig für eine soziale Mehrheit
für eine Mehrheit der Veränderung für
den Aufbau einer Alternative
in einigen Regionen bildet VOX diese
Alternative mit den Konservativen und
VOX will das auf Landesebene fortsetzen
sie setzt auf nationalistische
zuwanderungsfeindliche und EU kritische
Töne
sie sagen dass sie eine Geldstrafe von
20.000 Euro für jeden abgelehnten
illegalen Einwanderer verhängen werden
nun vielleicht lohnt es sich die zu
bezahlen es lohnt sich um unsere
Identität unsere Sicherheit und auch
unseren Wohlstand zu bewahren
die radikalen Töne Spalten Spaniens
politische Landschaft vor der Wahl
stehen sich die Lage unversöhnlich
gegenüber
lockerei es gibt zwei Blöcke die sich in
der spanischen Politik konstituieren und
es ist unmöglich sich eine
Zusammenarbeit zwischen Ihnen
vorzustellen es sieht nicht so aus als
ob wir eine große Koalition in Sicht
haben
der Regierungschef und Sozialist Petrus
Sanchez steht unter Druck erspitzte
darum zu und macht WLAN Angst vor einem
weiteren Rechtsrock Sanchez wirft dem
konservativen Alberto nun jetzt fejo vor
mit Hilfe der extremen Rechten an die
Macht kommen
am 23 juli geht es nicht mehr um die
Alternativen wie bei bisherigen Wahlen
es geht darum ob Spanien weiterhin
Fortschritt macht wie in den vergangenen
40 Jahren oder ob die Herren Fähre und
abascal uns in eine furchtbare Zeit
zurückversetzen von der wir nicht wissen
wie sie endet
sie sollten so abstimmen dass sie die
Blöcke in Spanien überwinden
eine klare Mehrheit sorgt dafür dass wir
ohne extreme Vorankommen
die extreme blockiert Dinge aber Sie
wissen nicht wie man regiert
die Kandidaten der PP der Volkspartei
Marta Rivera de la Cruz besucht einen
Ort in den Bergen nördlich von Madrid
obwohl laut Umfragen die PP wenn
überhaupt nur mit VOX regieren könne
behauptet sie etwas anderes da möglich
um der Frage auszuweichen
alleine zu regieren sie wird es
versuchen sie wird ein ausreichendes
Ergebnis haben um alleine regieren zu
können Koalition müssen nicht notwendig
sein
ein Präsident der tausend Lügen
Konservative und Sozialisten setzen mehr
auf Attacke und Angstmacher als auf
Programme unklar wem das am Ende mehr
nutzt verschärft wird die Unsicherheit
dadurch das Spanien zum ersten Mal im
Hochsommer wählt bei extremen
Temperaturen mitten in der Urlaubszeit
viele geben ihre Stimme schon jetzt ab
bei der Post sicher ist sicher denn es
geht um eine Richtungsentscheidung in
Spanien
[Musik]